before 2005
and we all looked at the waterfall but
they never went to the waterfall we were afraid
they also said children is not
dangerous to go there that they are going to die
they're going to love they're going to be short is
the mother of all cataracts counts
the story that there is a mermaid
lovely then nobody all the
generation came the children the grandchildren
the great-grandchildren came families but
nobody was going there
let's exhaust we're going to disappear
that at one time a little man was
had disappeared at the beginning of the
water and that was the fear that none
person had gone to visit the copla
up to a day
a tourist is called stefan ziemendorff
how is design
well well
doing and nobody wanted to go with him
says he climbed one of the walls
then he saw the gocta waterfall but
in rainy season as a water was
spectacular was very beautiful 2006
He returned as a civilian miner
they took it out in February and it was approved
as the third cataract
from 2005 to back June July August
everything was small farms
to plant ripoll corn no no no
much, much, we already suffered more like
I'm seeing what
to improve the quality of life in these
five years that we are working in the
tourism activity
so not such both forests do not
We make many farms
protecting
almost all were dangerous and from here
we looked at it that well because the rain
when I was growing up with nothing else but
we have never decided to go for a walk
every time we go we see it more beautiful
them being very spectacular for
We are not happy because I was already in
our boat hand were already in the
week I was afraid to go scary
but I had the impression that
there can happen something like that the mind
I had it while we did not have it there
near the goalkeeper
we have never visited him
and it was very nice
in a libya